[Music]
okay diabetes one-third of Americans
have diabetes it's higher in the black
community the Hispanic community is the
least in the Asian community okay
diabetes is a simple mineral deficiency
disease it's not genetic type 2 diabetes
makes up 98% of the diabetic population
in America and say simple mineral
deficiencies these we've known this
since 1957 we've known this since 1957
there's a simple mineral deficiency
disease and I take the mighty nine and I
take what we call the sweeties which is
the trace minerals necessary to support
promote I can legally say support
promote healthy carbohydrate and sugar
metabolism at the cellular level support
promote healthy blood sugar levels we've
already established that micromanaging
blood pressure doesn't save you from
being killed by high blood pressure and
micromanaging your blood sugar doesn't
save you from being killed by diabetes
because high blood sugar is just a
symptom of diabetes is not diabetes you
have to fix the cell walls okay next
next okay that little red thing on the
right side is supposed to represent a
what's called a receptor site on the
cell wall every cell in your body the
trillions and trillions of cells you
have in your body all have receptor
sites that are sensitive to insulin now
if you don't have these trace minerals
those receptor sites are not sensitive
to insulin most people who are type 2
diabetics have as much as 10 times more
insulin than a normal person there's not
that they lack insulin so why they
giving a more insulin trying to override
that system oftentimes doctors will tell
you have insulin resistant diabetes
because they are being honest with you
because they're telling you got plenty
of insulin you're just resistant to it
so the nice thing about this you take
the mighty 90 you take the sweeties
which has all these trace minerals and
what happens is you'll resent eyes those
receptor sites is you've got to watch it
though because your blood sugar will
drop right and so you have to take your
blood sugar every morning as you've been
empowered to do by your doctor and
you've also been empowered to adjust
your medication you do it you cheat all
the time
just have a piece of pecan pie a little
bit ice cream on I just take more of my
medicine and you know yeah you learn but
the a1c hemoglobin gives you away you
know you coded doctor oh yeah my blood
sugar is 90 this morning but your a1c is
14 instead of 5.2 you know you've been
naughty and so you got to watch it so
you take your blood sugar every morning
and as your blood sugar begins to drop
and it will very rapidly sometimes in 24
hours I've seen a drop 90 points in 24
hours gee you can't take the same amount
of insulin you got to take be faithful
take your blood sugar adjust your
medication has you've been in power to
do and when you wean off of your
medication you can go back to a normal
life but you have to stay on the mighty
19 you have to stay on the extra
sweeties it just goes away kind of a fun
way to add 25 healthful years your life
next that's what the sugar metabolism
looks like once the sugar gets inside
yourself now none of that happens if you
don't have these trace minerals to
sensitize that receptor site next this
is what doctors do for diabetes
Avandia killed a hundred thousand people
last year but it's been approved by the
FDA so you have your choice the mighty
90 and sweeties or Avandia may your
doctor will be just overjoyed to
prescribe Avandia to you but you start
talking to about the mighty 90 and the
sweeties and say all that that Wallach
you know he's one of them quack quack
quack duck kind of people okay next hmm
lifestyle approach for type 2 diabetes
the metabolic syndrome next okay next
you've read that well this is a big
study on forty four thousand black women
drinking juice causes more diabetes than
drinking soda pop drinking soda pop
increases your risk by 27 percent of
diabetes drinking juice brings it up by
31 percent now that doesn't cause it but
these women were all deficient in these
trace minerals and taking in the sugar
just sped up the process made it happen
quicker next okay so you know what to do
for diabetes you stay
away from all the steel you got away
from all the bad stuff right no fried
foods no processed meats you got to stay
away from sugar you got to take in the
mighty 90 plus the sweeties do your due
diligence take your blood sugar every
morning adjust your medication
appropriately because you've been
empowered to do and Shazam thank you
lord it's gone yes here's a good time
let's say on three thank you Lord on
three one two three
thank you lord oh I love that oh okay